-You know our first guest
from his work on
"Saturday Night Live."
He co-wrote and stars in
"The King of Staten Island,"
which is available
on demand now.
Here's my conversation with our
friend Pete Davidson.
Pete, buddy, it is
so nice to see you.
How are you doing?
-I'm good, man.
You know, just chillin' in
my mom's basement, being safe.
-That is -- The rumor was that
you were in your mom's basement.
I was on "Howard Stern"
this morning,
and he was saying that he
talked to you last week
and was busting you on the fact
that you have a movie
that you wrote and you starred
in and it's coming out
and there's no premiere party
and there's no red carpet
and you are, in fact,
in your mom's basement.
-Yep. Couldn't have
turned out better for me.
[ Both laugh ]
-There is something really
fitting on making
a movie that is -- I mean,
I think there's
been very few films that are
a love letter to Staten Island,
which I do believe this movie is
in a lot of ways.
And, yet, it seems like the
price you paid for that is --
you have to be in Staten Island
the week it opened.
Like, it did not allow you any
escape from Staten Island.
There is something
to the fact that this is,
I mean, a film about
Staten Island,
real people from Staten Island,
people who like being there,
who feel it's undervalued.
What have your friends
thought of the film?
Because, obviously,
you take a lot on your back
when you make a film
about your hometown.
-My friends really dug it.
The main comment I got
from my friends --
they would, like, pause
the movie and they would call me
and they'd be like, "Bro, I know
Marisa Tomei is your mom.
And don't take any offense to
this, but, bro, she's hot."
And I'm like, "There's
no offense to that at all.
It's a fictional -- Yeah."
So that's the
biggest comment I got.
-How does your mom feel about
the casting of Marisa Tomei?
-Oh, my mom's just thrilled.
We're all just such big fans.
And she's so incredible
and such a genius.
So, like, feel like
we got away with something.
Like, we're so thrilled
to have her in it.
-She's amazing.
Your grandfather is in the film.
-Yeah, my actual grandfather's
in the film.
He came to set every day
and hung out.
And he told me that he could
tell that I was doing well
because of the food
that they were serving.
He was like, "Peter,
there's pork chops today,
so I know everything's
going alright."
-Was it the plan from
the beginning to have him
in that graduation scene
or did he sort of talk his way
on to the set?
-I think Judd just pulled me
aside and was like,
"I think he would crush it."
And then I was like,
"Yeah, he probably would.
And then he arguably has
my favorite scene
in the entire movie.
-It's really funny.
Don't take this the wrong way,
but when he first
opened his mouth,
I had this thought --
"Oh, Pete knows that person."
It did not seem like
someone you found
via a normal casting table.
-Yeah. He really knocked it
out of the park.
We're really happy for him.
-So, you know, this movie is,
you know, based, obviously,
on your real life,
and, you know, the crux
of it is that you lost
your father,
who was a fireman, in 9/11.
I have heard you talk about that
onstage before,
but I have to imagine writing
about it for a film --
is it cathartic?
Is it painful?
Like, what was
that process like?
-It was a little bit of both.
I think it could've been a lot
worse if Judd and the crew
wasn't so sensitive
to my feelings.
They really made me
feel, like, comfortable.
So it was definitely more of
a cathartic experience,
and it definitely made me feel
a lot better as a person.
-Judd is, obviously, well-known
and deservedly receives
a lot of praise for helping
people tell their stories,
but before Judd got on board,
like, earlier drafts,
when it was just --
And who's the friend of yours
that you co-wrote it with?
-Oh, Dave Sirus,
the great Dave Sirus.
-So, you guys --
Early drafts were less about
this cathartic journey
and more about --
Well, why don't
you tell everybody
what the early drafts were like.
-Yeah. Originally,
it was just me and my friend
were writing this movie about
getting my mom laid,
and it just got
overly disgusting.
And then Judd turned it
and weaved it into this
120 pages of emotion
and an actual story,
so thank God for him.
-A far different film.
-A very different film for sure.
-You have some --
I mean, some classic,
well-known, great actors.
Like, we mentioned Marisa Tomei.
Steve Buscemi is outstanding.
-Oh, yeah.
-Bill Burr is fantastic.
One of my favorite stand-ups,
and he is just a great actor.
Is this someone you had always
wanted to play that part?
-Bill Burr is a hero of mine,
And I think he's the greatest
stand-up comic ever.
So, like,
Judd and I were just like,
"If there's any way
we can get him to do --"
He was another guy we were like,
"I hope we can
get him to do this,
you know, 'cause he's so great."
And it was a dream come true
getting to work with him.
He destroyed it.
-He was wonderful.
And it's really fun
to watch, you know,
someone you know as a stand-up,
like, just hold their own,
you know, in scenes with someone
like Marisa Tomei.
And I should also note,
I felt the same way about you.
Like, you and Bill are two
people I know sort of uniquely
from watching you
be versions of yourself.
It was really fun to watch
this movie
and sort of forget you
were Pete.
It was great.
I mean, did you feel --
Is the burden of acting --
And I know you've done movies,
but is the burden of acting
when you are playing a version
of yourself bigger or is it
do you feel more comfortable?
-Oh, I felt a lot
more comfortable,
because it's just like,
"If nobody likes this,
it's just they don't like me."
It's not like
I was reaching or anything.
It's just people
just don't like me.
That was my way out of it.
-You said your Staten Island
friends have been pleased with
the way that the film
turned out.
Were people excited when
there was a film set
on Staten Island
in the beginning?
-People from Staten Island
would -- It's very --
A lot of people
were excited about it,
but a lot of people were,
like, very frustrated
with the traffic
that it brought.
-I see.
-Like, you know how,
normally, like,
if anybody's shooting anything
and people will
stop by and be like,
"What is this?
Oh, my God. This is amazing."
A lot of people would stop by
and be like,
"Hey, you're blocking
my driveway."
-You know what?
I can't believe
it took this long,
considering the show
is based in New York,
but I think it's safe to say
this is the first era
in "SNL" where there are
two actors, two cast members,
from Staten Island,
you and Colin Jost.
-Yeah.
-Colin also did a movie called
"Staten Island Summer."
Do you think he regrets
now going first
and not naming his movie
"The King of Staten Island"?
-Probably. I don't know.
Colin's crushing it in Montauk
with the waves, man.
Colin doesn't care about
the Internet fodder.
Colin's destroying the world.
-He's "The Monarch of Montauk."
That's what you're saying.
-Yeah. He's the man.
-Alright, we're going to
come back with more
Pete Davidson right after this.